تحطمت طائره ركاب النيباليه علمتنيها 72
راكبا وذلك بمقاطعه بخاره وسط البلاد صباح
اليوم واعلن سلطات الطيران المدني في
نيبال انتشال 40 جثه من حطام الطائره
المنكوبه وهي من طراز اي تي ار 72
ان رئيس الوزراء عقد اجتماعا طارئا
للحكومه في مطار تريبي هوفان في العاصمه
كتماندو لبحث اسباب الحادث وتداعيته واقل
لمتحدث
للطيران التي تملك الطائره قال ان الطائره
المنكوبه كانت في رحله من مدينه بخارى الى
العاصمه كاتماندو وكان على مثلها ثمانيه
وستون راكبا اضافه الى اربعه هم افراد
الطاقه
بدورها عبر رئيس الوزراء النيباليه بوشبا
كمال دهال عن حزنه العميق لتحطم الطائره
ومسرع الضحايا
قوه
مؤسسات الحكومه والمواطنين لبدء ما سماها
عمليه انقاذ فعال في موقع تحطم الطائره من
جانبه قال مدير مطار تريب هوفان النيفلي
ان طاقم الطائره المنكوبه كان على اتصال
ببرج المراقبه حتى اللحظه الاخيره
انه لم يبلغ برج المراقبه بوجود مشاكل
لافتا الى ان الطائره سقطت اثناء
استعدادها للهبوط
تنضم الينا من كتامندوق الصحفيه شرستي
كافال لسيده شرستي الى اين وصلت عمليات
البحث والانقاذ وما هو العدد النهائي
للقتلى
اه اه
حصول الحادث هذا الصباح قامت السلطات
المحليه وخاصه قوات الامن
كل السلطات من اجل تسريع عمليات البحث
والانقاد التي ما تزال مستمر بالنسبه
للسرطان اعلانات لانه تم ايجاد 40 جثه لحد
الان في موقع الحادث
من المتوقع ان يرتفع هذا الرقم
لذلك الان فان اجتماع رئيس الوزراء يجري
الان نحن نتوقع المزيد من التعليمات
والتصريحات ربما الاجراءات بين السرطان
سيد فلسطين هل هنالك اي
اشارات حول الاسباب التي ادت الى تحطم هذه
الطائره ربما الوقت مبكر لان نعرف الاسباب
بشكل دقيق ولكن هل هنالك اي تلميح من قبل
السلطات حول اسباب الحادث
في النيبال
الجغرافيه المعقده لكن في هذا الحادث لم
نرى وجودا له سببين لان كانت الطائره على
بعد كيلو مترين فقط من المطار وكانت
الحاله الجويه جيد جدا
ربما كان يحاول ان
لايك صومالي لو كنت ساكن
المباني المحليه والبيوت كان هنالك ربما
بعض المعلومات انه كان يحاول ان يتجنب
السقوط على بعض المباني
والبيوت المحليه لكن في حقيقه الامر ليس
هناك اي تاكيد حول سبب الحقيقي وراء
التحكم هذه الطائره لكن كما ذكرت الطقس
الموقع الجغرافيا بالقرب من المطار كان
جيد التالي
بسبب قدمي الطائرات هذه احد الاسباب هذه
التخمينات فقط
امكانيات وجود اي ناجين
اه تبي رحاب
التاكيد لان السلطات المحليه في بكره احد
المسؤولين قال انه لا يرى اي فرصه لوجودي
ناجين وكان هناك رد فعل
من
الجمهور طبعا من العمل
جثه لكن
انعدام
همم كره من اللهب حاطت بالطائره اثناء
تحطمها بالتالي هذا يقلل فرصه وجود ناجي
شكرا كريستيانو